what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so you guys really seemed to enjoy
characters that are to overpower to be
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so in
this one we're swinging for the fences
we're gonna have some fun God king doom
yes do I love God king doom okay God
king doom is amazing Doctor Doom with
the power of the beyonders isn't saying
okay so preface here so when Marvel
Comics in 2012 running up until 2015
they decided they kind of wanted to
reboot but not really that is sort of
use it as like a marketing ploy like we
might be rebooting we might not I kind
of feel like they were supposed to but
it doesn't matter because we got
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers one of the best runs ever so
the way this happened was that like
universes were basically dying and
nobody really knew why all they knew is
that there were the incursions that you
would be sitting on earth one day in
some universe or in the main Marvel
Universe and then you would see another
earth and like from the time you saw it
until like and and like for the next
eight hours they would move closer to
each other if one of the earths was not
destroyed then the universes would crash
into each other and they would both be
destroyed but if you destroyed one of
the other Earth's
then the universes would just pass
through each other and nothing would
happen and so like this whole thing goes
on like for a long time there's so many
badass moments dude black panther
reforms the Illuminati dude is like one
of the coolest things ever black
panthers like he's like mother saved me
from from what I'm about to do save me
from like thinkers which is Reed
Richards and like righteous men Tony
Stark Iron Man and like midnight Kings
Black Bolt of the Inhumans and the devil
himself which is like aa name with a
submariner because during the Avengers
vs. x-men story name of the Submariner
destroyed what contra didn't really
swear but like he he like flooded
Wakanda and destroyed the necropolis
which is like the burial ground for like
all former Black Panthers that that's
where Black Panther became king of the
Dead when he lost his powers and sure he
became the new black panther so like
this is this really cool thing like he
reforms them all and they're like
they're like we have to figure out
what's going on in Reed Richards is like
okay so like the incursions are
happening which basically means whenever
an earth pops up we have eight hours to
destroy it or figure out what we're
gonna do so like okay let's assemble the
Infinity Gauntlet so like everybody have
their Infinity stones you know like yep
we all have our Infinity stones but it
is it is up turning out that because
Charles Xavier died he's not there he
died in Avengers vs. x-men and so he
bequeathed his Infinity stones to his
mind stone to beast and so so beast
gives it Hank McCoy gets it and then he
joins the Illuminati and they're like
okay we all have the Infinity stones
assemble the Infinity Gauntlet they're
like who's gonna wield it and they're
like well of course you're gonna wheel
to Captain America dude it's like the
most badass moment ever like like
they're like okay are you ready cap and
he's like yeah and he puts on the
gauntlet he's like
so much power and he's just like I can
feel the whole universe then he goes to
push the universal way like to push the
the in cursing earth away and like the
Infinity stones shatter and the time
stone vanishes and it's just like holy
cow like okay so like they're kind of
screwed now and then from that point
going forward you basically run into
like the Illuminati hitting the panic
button at every turn and trying to find
a way to stop the incursions and then
like oh do here's a crazy thing after
that after the Infinity Gauntlet
destroyed they have this meeting where
were they all sit down and they say okay
so like what are we gonna do and reads
like we're gonna do the only thing that
we can do we're gonna destroy every
single earth that shows up then tries to
destroy ours and Captain America is like
no we're not doing that we're not taking
innocent life and in an Iron Man's like
I'm sorry I came to this Steve he's like
dr. strange do it and and and Captain
America is like what are you talking
about and dr. strange wipes his mind and
like makes him forget everything and
then they just send him back out again
and it's like what a massive betrayal
and so so then um captain like Captain
America realizes what's going on because
of the events of original sin and like
he's lost the Super Soldier Serum by now
so he's like an old man and so he's
director of shield and he's like after
the Illuminati every single resource we
have sinned after the Illuminati so then
it turns into a cat-and-mouse game and
it goes on like that for like for so
long like the Illuminati are constantly
on the run trying to stop the incursions
and Captain America's leading shield and
constantly chasing after them eventually
like everything seems to come to a head
and there's other stuff too right
there's other things that go on like the
like what is it the the black priests
and then oh dude no and then Doctor
Strange goes to the sinners market and
and which I like it was it was a crazy
so he goes to the sinners market and
goes to like to the to the bartering
goes to the place to barter for power
and they're like well you like your soul
like you have to trade a portion of your
soul for a portion of power so 10% of
your soul for 10% of absolute power and
dr. strange is like I want it all I want
100% of my soul for 100% of the absolute
power and they're just like no one's
done that before so what you end up
finding out is like earlier in the story
which we didn't know a Hank Pym ant-man
was sent into the multiverse by Reed
Richards by that by by mr. fantastic
from the Fantastic Four in order to try
to find a way to find either the source
of the incursions or to stop the
incursions but he eventually comes back
and they're like oh my god was your
mission a success and he was like
absolutely not we are so screwed you
have no idea what's out there and
they're like what's out there he's like
the beyonders are here and they're like
holy because the last time we saw beyond
her was in Secret Wars in 1984 and like
it was insane like this thing this thing
crushed Galactus like it like it just
flicked Galactus back like it's like a
speck this was a thing that was so
powerful like like the original Beyonder
was so powerful the Living Tribunal
couldn't stop it and that's like the
second most powerful being in the
entirety of the multiverse short only to
the one above all and so it's just like
if we're fighting like an army of these
things and Hanks like no no no that was
a little date that was a child unit
these are the parents like these are
these are these are the grown folk and
like and and they they are pissed and so
he starts telling his story right he's
like okay so basically I shrunk down to
like like miniscule levels and I grew to
like huge levels can I kind of basically
slip through like the fabric of the
universe I was so small I could slip
through the fabric of the universe and
go from one universe to the next he's
like then I come across the universe
what the beyonders are killing every
single cosmic entity like every
celestial they're killing eternity it
gets so bonkers the battle is so extreme
and so outrageous that eventually it
starts to like distort and warp the
fabric of space and time and so the
result is him watching universes begin
to blend into each other and that's when
they that's when he realizes the be
honors that are killing the cosmic
entities in this one universe that's
only a part of it there's other
beyonders killing other cosmic entities
across like the entire multiverse and so
eventually like the Living Tribunal pops
up and The Living Tribunal is just like
like what is going on here and the
beyonders like what's going on here is
that you're dead and like they kill him
they destroy a living tribunal and like
a fraction of them falls in every single
universe so this eventually segues into
like the huge revelation right and what
you end up finding out is there's this
guy named molecule man Owen Reese who's
super powerful and his history was
always kind of shady and Marvel Comics
is always kind of shaky but what you
learn is that molecule man his origin
story is the same across every single
universe and the reason why is because
he's basically a walking talking bomb
that what the beyonders wanted to do is
they wanted to basically plant a
molecule man in every single universe
and then detonate them all at the same
time just to see what would happen but
like dr. doom realized what was going on
like dr. doom and molecule man realize
what was going on they went to another
universe to try to stop it and destroy
that universes molecule man but what I
did is it created a cascading effect
because that universe blew up it pushed
the universes next to it into the
universes next to those and so like it
just creates this domino effect we're
like universes start bumping into each
other so basically like over the span of
something like like six days the entire
multiverse basically collapses and like
everyone's
no it's like it's like one day like like
every universe is collapsing they're all
dying they're all like almost completely
and totally obliterated and so then you
have like dr. doom dr. strange in the
molecule man who were like the last
three men left alive aside from those
who escaped in the raft so like Reed
Richards Black Panther spider-man Peter
Parker spider-man Miles Morales a couple
other people I think and then you have
the villains so like Thanos survives and
then like a handful of other people but
anyway so like Doctor Doom uses the
combined power of the molecule man Owen
Reese and Doctor Strange channels it
into himself and destroys the beyonders
right so like dr. doom annihilus if he
honors in their entirety and then takes
all their power and becomes God King
dude and he's wearing like all white and
it's like the coolest thing ever but
this this guy is like nigh unstoppable
it's insane with a wave of his hand he
destroys Doctor Strange
he like punches of his hand through a
nose his chest grabs his spine and then
disintegrates him I mean it's just crazy
stuff like that T'Challa like Black
Panther has the Infinity Gauntlet and
just gets annihilated he's just like
like his Doctor Strange after he had
died he had left his kind of Kapoor in
corporeal form like this more or less
like a message like a voicemail for
Black Panther in the form of like a
spiritual voicemail if there was such a
thing and was like hey so battleworld is
composed of basically what's left of the
multiverse meaning there's different
universes here I've collected an
infinity stone from each one of these
universes or from like six or five or
six of these universes and so the
Infinity Gauntlet will work on battle
world and so so like Black Panthers like
dude okay this is our one chance to win
he shows up like he did he takes over
the dead he shows up to the zombie like
to the place where all the Marvel
Zombies are and he's like I'm king of
the Dead and like commands the zombies
to fight on his behalf leads them in
like this massive war against Doctor
Doom you have like a planet full of
incredible hulks all of whom are led by
maestro whole fighting against fighting
against Doctor Doom you got the villain
apocalypse who's like wrecking the
entire thor core by himself like the
entire army of like an army of force
groot thor and storm thor and like
ultimate universe thor and main marvel
universe story but he's just like
wrecking them all by himself and so like
like all this stuff is popping off the
black panther runs up on dr. Dean with
the Infinity Gauntlet
and he's like we had this and in doctor
dooms like no you don't and like he's
like you're done and and like that's it
like its power just did like destroys
the power of the Infinity Gauntlet and
it's just it's just I mean it's it's
insane how much power he has and at that
point when you're talking about like and
this is why he could never fit in the
MCU you're talking about Doctor Doom
wielding a power like like having full
totality of the power of beings who were
powerful enough to destroy the Living
Tribunal to destroy the being design
until like safeguard the multiverse to
make sure like there's no magical
imbalance the one above all created the
Living Tribunal for that purpose
nothing supposed to be more powerful
than the Living Tribunal the beyonders
annihilated him with like three blasts
like three energy blasts and annihilated
him in his entirety but nonetheless like
you can never have that version of
Doctor Doom in the MCU because he's just
so damn powerful nobody would stand a
chance there's there's no conceivable
way you could even reduce his power to
make it believable cuz you have to go
into who the beyonders are and what
they're about and what they're capable
of and why they're so dangerous and why
it matters you stole their power
otherwise you might as well just steal
the power of Doctor Strange so like why
do you have that you have to go into
that whole thing and explain like why
they're so capable and why they're so
dangerous and why like everybody's
screwed that was basically yet man dr.
doom got the Infinity Gauntlet got the
power the B honors and it's like dude
we're so screwed man this guy's gonna
kill us all and there's there's nothing
we can do it isn't taking Reed Richards
to like face off against dr. doom he
ends up making dr. doom admit that like
doom believes Reed Richards is better
and then like like in the middle of it
like molecule man asked a question like
do you believe Reed Richards could have
done could have done all this better
than you could have and dr. doom says
yes like he kind of grudgingly says yes
and so like the molecule man takes the
power the beyonders away from from dr.
doom gives it to Reed Richards and like
Reed Richards fixes everything cuz you
know but he's a good guy so good guys
dude so like it's one of the coolest
things ever but like do god-king doom is
just is so broken like he's he's
overpowered broken it's amazing but I'd
love to see him in the MCU but there's
no way to do that like there's there's
no way to bring him in and make him that
powerful having said that we could get
the version of Doctor Doom from secret
Wars in 1984 the first seeker wars when
he stole the power of Galactus but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later purse
[Music]